Believe it or not, the Sonic the Hedgehog
movie is finally on the way.
If you want to know more details about the
film, then you've come to the right place.
This is everything we know about the Blue
Blur's big screen debut, and why you should
be looking forward to it.
Sonic the Hedgehog was already supposed to
be upon us.
The film has been in development since 2013,
but the production really ramped up in 2017
and 2018.
The original release was scheduled for November
8, 2019, but the first trailer in April of
2019 caused such a negative reaction - particularly
to the title character's design - that the
studio pulled the film back to work on some
alterations.
However, it appears the redesigned film is
finally up to snuff, as the new release date
of February 14, 2020 seems like it is set
in stone.
If your idea of a romantic Valentine's Day
date is with a blue anthropomorphic hedgehog
wearing sneakers, then you are in luck in
2020.
After the controversy that swirled around
the original trailer, the reworked version
released in November of 2019 has received
much more praise for being faithful to the
tone of the franchise.
It does a decent job of setting the stage:
Sonic - voiced by Ben Schwartz - is a lonely
alien who lives on Earth and is bored out
of his mind.
After he causes a huge power surge, several
forces start converging to try to capture
Sonic and harness his powers, which he tells
us could let them "conquer the universe."
One of those forces is Jim Carrey's Dr. Robotnik.
"Give me a BIG, FAT BREAK!"
Otherwise, the trailer shows a lot of references
to Sonic video games, showcases the film's
sense of humor, and focuses on two central
things: Robotnik's weapons and the friendship
between Sonic and Tom - played by James Marsden.
It seems like a pretty strong showcase of
the movie's tone, so you'll have a good idea
what you're getting into before you decide
if you want to see Sonic the Hedgehog.
The director of Sonic the Hedgehog, Jeff Fowler,
has an interesting pedigree.
He's been nominated for an Oscar, albeit in
the category for "Best Animated Short."
That nomination - shared with Deadpool and
Terminator: Dark Fate director Tim Miller
- comes courtesy of his time in the director's
chair for the 2004 film Gopher Broke.
Otherwise... that's it.
Yes, Fowler only has one directorial credit
to his name, and it's an animated short film
from over a decade ago.
That's potentially a bit disheartening.
Of course, Fowler has worked on a few different
films in different departments, including
a stint on the visual effects team for Where
the Wild Things Are.
Sonic's screenplay credit is shared among
Josh Miller, Patrick Casey, and Oren Uziel.
The first two worked together writing films
like Transylmania and Dorm Daze.
Uziel's portfolio includes contributions to
22 Jump Street and The Cloverfield Paradox.
Essentially, it's an eclectic combination
of writing experience and untested directorial
talent that will hopefully come together to
make something fun with Sonic the Hedgehog.
There aren't a ton of details about the actual
plot of the Sonic the Hedgehog film, but here's
what we know.
The official synopsis reads: "Sonic tries
to navigate the complexities of life on Earth
with his newfound best friend - a human named
Tom Wachowski.
They must soon join forces to prevent the
evil Dr. Robotnik from capturing Sonic and
using his powers for world domination."
So, we know Sonic is an alien who teams up
with James Marsden's character.
He can apparently use the golden rings as
teleportation portals, as the film's trailer
shows him doing this a few times.
And we know Dr. Robotnik wants to capture
Sonic to harness his powers and use them for
his own personal gain.
The tone and general plot beats we've seen
in the trailer showcase the film as being
a bit of an oddball buddy film with some slapstick
action thrown in.
It will be interesting to see how much explanation
the film offers of Sonic and his abilities.
Maybe it will just say something to the effect
of, "Well, he's a super powerful alien.
What more do you need?"
"How are you not dead?"
"I have no idea!"
Let's talk about the hedgehog in the room:
the reaction to the first Sonic the Hedgehog
trailer was loud and angry.
Our hero was originally made to look considerably
more... realistic than the version we're getting.
Well, as realistic as a humanoid cartoon hedgehog
can look.
It… did not work.
The off-putting design, coupled with the "trying
too hard" punchlines, caused a massive outcry
from fans.
Sonic was mocked relentlessly, and the studio
actually listened.
Director Jeff Fowler took to Twitter to reassure
fans that Sega and Paramount got the message,
quote, "loud and clear," punctuating the promise
with the hashtag "#gottafixfast."
And fix it fast they did.
The film was delayed as the team went back
to the drawing board with Sonic's design,
reportedly costing the production an extra
$5 million.
It actually seemed to work.
Upon release of the official "redesigned"
trailer, fan reaction was almost the complete
opposite of the first time around.
The redesigned Sonic actually resembled the
character that fans loved, and the response
to the trailer was extremely positive.
You see?
Fans on the internet sometimes can bring about
good change!
Of course, in the movie business, a happy
ending sometimes hides a grim story.
Despite some skepticism, it seems like the
crew of the Sonic movie pulled off the mighty
task of redesigning their main character and
starting over from scratch on no small number
of completed visual effects sequences.
MPC Vancouver, the studio that redesigned
the character, was promptly rewarded for their
efforts by… being shut down.
That's a pretty steep price to pay for Sonic's
teeth to not induce nightmares.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.